- Okay, so wait, next we're gonna go to-
What's interesting little number, so-
- [Oscar] Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's from me too.
That's actually from Mr.
Tight Sleeves over here.
I heard you had a new book.
- [Kelly] Oh, you know what,
I'm gonna pass this off.
This is for you.
- That's actually a bookmark.
- Nice, nice.
- [Kelly & Oscar] Yeah.
- [Oscar] Scratch and sniff too.
- [Kelly] Yegh! Scratch and sniff.
- Never lose your place.
Yep.
- Ugh.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- This smells terrible.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah, really terrible.
- He's like, "You're welcome." (laughs)
Wait, who are these? Whose are these?
What are these?
- Wait a minute.
You look like a monster.
- [Kelly] Yeah, okay.
- You look like a "Sesame Street" monster-
- Not the first time I've been told, yeah.
- [Elmo] No, no, no.
- [Arnold] Try those on.
- I want you to try these on. Try that on.
Come on. You think you're good
looking now, wait a minute.
(audience laughs)
- Hey yo, hey yo.
- [Kelly] Exactly, exactly.
- I'll be back.
(Elmo laughs)
(audience cheers)
- Ready for Halloween? I like it.
Wait.
- I should have had those
when I did "Terminator."
- [Kelly] I know.
(everyone laughs)
No, trust me, your
glasses were cool in that.